[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
My purpose in making this video is quite simply that I see the colorization of
these photographs as an extremely effective way to connect on a deeper level to
the past.
There is of course a value to photographs in their original black and white
state,
but too many people,
especially those of us who were born at a time in which car photography became
the norm or the lack of color in these historic photographs almost seems to
separate us from those time periods,
these images from the civil war world war one,
even world war two seem almost like our civilizations faded memories,
distant remnants of our past.
When you add color to them,
you realize just how important of a factor colorist to connecting in a sense of
something to relate to it.
Viewing is so worse orders.
For example,
he seemed like ghosts in black and white,
like ancient history,
add color and the picture comes alive.
You can place yourself was in it much easier.
Their uniforms and their environment and their flesh are compared to the
original,
all the more alive.
You know there's picture from World War One could have been taken the other day
and that was over a hundred years ago.
It's easier to form a mental picture of and naturally ask and relate to what it
might've been like on that day as opposed to a colorless antique of an archaic
war.
We've only had photography since the early 19th century.
This photo taken around 1826 is the earliest known photograph.
That's incredible.
We can go back that far and see something,
a photograph,
and of course,
keep in mind this has been greatly enhance from the 1820s just a decade after
the Napoleonic wars,
only 50 years after the American war of independence.
That's really cool in my opinion,
but it means we've only been taking photographs for a little under 200 years and
color photographs only we can a norm in the 1960s which is almost about 60
years,
but the past 9,800 years of human civilization or so prior,
there are zero photographs and we can connect to those times through art and
continuation of culture and language and various things of that nature.
But it's needless to say,
that photography,
how has allowed us to connect to our past in a way that has not been seen in
history.
So while again,
these original black and whites are valuable in their own right,
adding colors,
and he's older.
Photographs,
in my opinion,
helps to maximize our ability to connect with our human past.
For more videos like this and videos on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.